The Washington Post recently wondered is
it better to work out at night or in the
morning well I say it's better to have
worked out you know
a week ago but according to a new study
women burn more belly fat if they work
out in the morning I did not know this
did anyone know this no now we do huh
um and I have to do it in the morning or
I will lose the Mojo it's like morning
or never yeah however if you are a lady
who likes to pump iron strength training
is more effective at night it all has to
do with our internal clocks it affects
our physiology
so that's fascinating I didn't know that
I didn't know that I just have to say if
you morning or night if you're going to
the gym though congratulations you know
it's just
[Applause]